peter ich weiß gar nicht ob du uns
verstehen kannst ob du und sehen kannst
ja ich glaube die verbindung die steht
doch sie hören und wir sehen es große
unruhe weil die peter kann sonst einmal
erklären was da gerade los ist warum nun
wieder so große unruhe ist optimist wir
hören sich ja peter legt los also ich
glaube ihr hört nicht jetzt geht die
polizei ist jetzt
mit einer viel zeit rigoros vor es viel
zeit gesehen einer der daten hat auch
das quellen der hand also hier wird mit
allen mitteln gegen die demonstranten
vorgegangen um die apps von hier
von diesem ort berichten da haben sie
mir glauben oder gar die und israel
bombardierten berufen also ist widerlich
israel-hass hier auf der sonnenallee in
neukölln polizei nimmt der zweite
verteidiger fest jetzt hier einen
gegenstand geflogen und hätten das war
aber es war irgendwas flüssiges stimmung
ist dass ich jetzt auch gegen die
polizei reagiere dann eben mit
festnahmen hat das alles verstehe
gezückt um so eventuell gegen die games
sondern ein zusätzliches wurde gegen
einigen demonstranten eingesetzt ja
wer vorne jemand von dieser straße weg
gebracht die polizei nur in größeren
gruppen hier ein im ring teil eben die
beamten die dann eben den einen
demonstranten fest leben um sich gegen
etwaige auswirkungen also einwirkung von
demonstranten zu schützen da sehen wir
das wieder wie die polizei sich dort in
der mitte versammelt im grund kreis in
der mitte ein zweiter und festgenommen
werden
dann zeige ich jetzt hier ruhig aber
konsequent praktisch jetzt fliegen
wieder flaschen gegenstände
jetzt kommen die beamten hier
später erst mal vielen dank dass ihr da
so großartig die stellung halten
das ist wirklich momente wie man sie nur
ganz selten im fernsehen eben sieht und
erlebt dass reporter live neben einer
polizeikette stehen und einfangen wenn
dann die polizei vorgeht gegen
aggressive demonstranten und ja unser
kamerateam also einen meter daneben
steht wenn ja gewaltbereite
demonstranten rausgezogen werden
festgenommen werden ihre personalien
festgestellt werden und was wir eben
auch sehen ist wie dieser dämons
demonstrationszug aggressiv nach setzt
gegen die polizeikette und so wirkt es
zumindest in diesem augenblick die
polizeikette auch ein stück weit vor
sich hertreibt gefährliche situation auf
jeden fall auch für unseren peter passen
weiter auf dich auf